[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS LATIMER:
Hello, and welcome
to Cloud OnAir, the live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
these every Tuesday.
My name is Chris Latimer.
I'm a product manager
here at Google.
I focus on is an API management.
And I'm joined by my
esteemed colleague.
SCOTT GANYO: Hi.
My name is Scott Ganyo.
I'm a software engineer.
And I've been working
on the adapter
that you're about
to see for Mixer.
CHRIS LATIMER: And
today we're going
to be talking about the role
of API management and the Istio
service mesh.
So let's start off by talking
about what a service mesh is
and why we need one.
So if you're like
most companies,
you probably have a
lot of people thinking
that microservices are awesome.
You're probably looking at
ways to adopt microservices
and build a microservices-based
architecture.
But why exactly do we
need microservices?
If you think about the
alternative, what we typically
call a monolith, there's
a lot of good things
about a monolith.
For one thing, it's usually
in one big code base.
So if you're going to work on
a monolith, it's really easy.
We just have to clone one repo.
We're usually working
on a single project.
We're usually building just
one thing, running one thing.
It's really easy to get
started with a monolith.
Usually, where monoliths
break down is that they grow
and they keep growing
and growing and growing,
and not just from a code
base standpoint, but also
the number of people that
are working on monoliths.
And so when that happens, we
start to run into challenges.
Usually, we start to have
to coordinate our releases.
And when we look at
really big companies that
are building these
monoliths, these mission
critical monoliths,
it's not uncommon
that they can only release
two or three times a year.
And so when we're trying
to get increased agility
from our organization,
it's really hard
to do with a
monolith, especially
as they start to grow.
And it's around that point
that most organizations
start to look at microservices.
So microservices have
a number of advantages.
They address a lot
of the concerns
that we have with monoliths.
So instead of having
one big code base,
we can decompose a monolith
into a number of microservices.
These microservices usually have
some kind of bounded context.
We have a dedicated team
that works on these.
They're independently
deployable,
independently scalable.
And when we start to
look at orchestrating
all of these microservices to
work together to form a system,
we usually think
of this or refer
to this as a service mesh.
Now, this isn't to
say that microservices
are a perfect solution.
If you look at what
happens as microservices
grow and your service
mesh starts to grow,
you'll run into a
number of challenges.
So when we try to look at
things like dependencies
across services,
this is fairly easy
when you have a small
set of microservices.
As they start to
increase, figuring out
what depends on
something else is tricky.
One of the things that we
like about microservices
is that they are
independently deployable.
So if you have a change
to a microservice,
you can deploy that
without necessarily
waiting for everything
else to be deployed.
But that's not always the case.
You may have situations
where you have
dependencies on these services.
So if you have a
change that's breaking,
you want to understand
who's breaking
and you want to have a way to
manage those dependencies so
that you can
minimize the impact.
The other thing is,
with the monolith,
if we all of a sudden
have a problem,
maybe an exception
happens, we've
got a stack trace that tells
us the entire application.
Where did this problem
originate from?
When you're looking across
the mesh of microservices,
that's a trickier
problem to solve,
to be able to pinpoint exactly
where the problem is occurring.
And so as you start
to look at those,
those are some hard
problems to solve.
And you might be thinking
to yourself, well, gosh,
are microservices that great?
And the good news is just
about every technology
that we've ever
used has some type
of challenge associated
with it and microservices
are no different.
And when that happens,
what we tend to do
is we look to build out tools
and frameworks and platforms
that are going to solve
hard problems for us
so that we can focus on the
business value and the business
logic that we want
to build and we want
to run in our microservices.
And that's really what Istio
is trying to do for us.
And there are-- so let me talk a
little bit what Istio is first.
So it's an open source platform
for solving these problems
that we've just described.
It's a collaboration between
Google, IBM, Lyft, Cisco--
many other companies
are all working together
to build out this platform.
And the platform really
has three main areas
that it looks to address.
So the first is
around observability.
So if you think
about microservices,
we're building these
in different languages.
We might be building
microservices in Go, in Java,
C++, Python, whatever
language you may prefer.
But all those microservices--
we want to be able to look
at a common set of data.
We want to be able to look
across those services,
understand how are
they performing.
Are we seeing an uptick in
errors across these services?
How much traffic is flowing
through these microservices?
And we don't necessarily
want to build that
into each and every
microservice individually.
What we would rather do
is delegate that down
to a platform.
In this case, Istio provides
that capability for you
to solve that problem.
The other challenge
is around agility.
So again, I mentioned
if all of a sudden
we're deploying a new
version of a microservice,
we don't necessarily
want to break everything
that depends on that.
And so in order to
accomplish that,
we might want to do things
like roll out a canary version.
So we want to see if we
actually break something, maybe
send a small percentage
of traffic to it.
We want to handle routing
to the appropriate service,
to the appropriate
version of the service.
Again, that becomes
very easy with Istio.
And then, of course,
just like anything else
we different
technical standpoint,
security is going to
be a paramount concern.
And we want to be able to
apply security very easily.
So the way that we
accomplish this in Istio
is with three main
control plane components.
We've got Pilot.
Pilot's going to be responsible
for all the configuration
of Istio.
So when you're ready to
deploy a microservice
and apply policies to it, you're
going to interact with Pilot.
Now, those policies are
going to be enforced
by something called Mixer.
So normally, we
want to apply things
like traffic management
or a rate limiting.
We want to put in
place security checks.
The way that those
security checks are defined
as in policies and the
way they're enforced
is with a component
called Mixer,
and we'll talk a little bit
more about Mixer coming up.
And then, finally,
we have Citadel.
So Citadel is what's going
to handle all of the network
security for us.
It's going to provide
service-to-service
authentication authorization
using mutual TLS.
So what exactly can we do with
the security aspects of Istio?
Well, the first
thing is we are going
to be able to use
mutual TLS to identify
the service and the
service consumer.
So because it's
mutual TLS, we're
going to have assurance
that we know exactly which
services is making a
call in and we're also
going to be able to apply
authorization rules.
So we're going to
be able to say,
is this service allowed to call
another service in our mesh?
And we could even go one
degree finer as well.
We can actually have
fine-grained rules
around that service, the
service communication.
So maybe I have
an invoice service
and that invoice service
has two types of consumers.
Maybe one of those
consumers is allowed
to have a read-only access.
Maybe one's allowed
to have full access.
And with Istio, we're able
to provide the capabilities
for applying those rules.
Now, those rules are
actually enforced by Mixer.
So with Mixer what we
can do is we can say,
we've got Citadel,
which has provided
a secure channel
of communication
across all of these different
service interactions,
but we may also have
policy-based enforcement
that we want to apply as well.
Mixer is the extensible
platform that allows
us to enforce these policies.
So Mixer has a number
of integrations
that are pre-built. So
we've got integrations
with Apigee, with Stackdriver,
with Zipkin, with many others.
And so it is very easy for
us to take a microservice
and quickly apply
these policies,
quickly apply
transport-level security
across all the communication.
And all of that is
configured using Pilot.
So Pilot is going to be the
mechanism that we interact
with that's going to take
all of those components
and allow us to push a
configuration across it
across everything.
And even though these
may sound like there's
a lot of things going on,
we've made it extremely easy
for you to use with Istio.
All you need to do is write
a few snippets of YAML
to describe your service, to
describe the policies that you
want to enforce on
the services, push
those in and all of a sudden,
Istio takes care of the rest.
So you've now got a
feeling for what Istio is
and all the components.
Let's take a look now at how
it actually works in practice.
SCOTT GANYO: OK.
Wow.
As you can see, Istio
does a lot for you, right?
I'm not going to have time
to go through all of that
because we're going to want to
get to API management in a bit.
But I do want to show you
a little bit about what
Istio does.
And this this is
the Bookinfo app.
This is the architecture for it.
It's a simple app
that comes with Istio.
As you can see, it just has
a page that you can hit.
It has a login thing and a
bunch of different versions
of a review service.
And one of the features,
as you talked about
with the microservices,
is all of these
are running in
different environments,
different languages.
So we have Python, Java, node,
Ruby all working together
for this one app.
So let's get in.
Let me show you.
So what I did here is I just
installed Istio on Kubernetes--
Bookinfo and a gateway so
that you can access it.
And I'm just going to show
you what that page looks like.
So this is the details
page for one of the books,
"The Comedy Of Errors."
And as I refresh,
what you'll see
is different versions
of the review service.
Now normally, you might
go in and, as you said,
you might have a
canary or something.
Like, I want to take version
1 and then apply version 2 to,
like, 20% of traffic.
Or maybe just a tester
can access that.
And so I can do all that.
But what I want to
show you is some
of the cool stuff that
happens after the fact
in the telemetry.
And we have all
these plug-ins that
are available for Jaeger,
ServiceGraph, Grafana,
Prometheus.
And I just wanted to show you,
for example, the ServiceGraph.
So when I was hitting
refresh on that page earlier,
this was actually
being generated.
This actually shows
you how your request
is traveling through
the system and which
versions you're hitting.
You can see review version
3, ratings, version 1,
things like that.
CHRIS LATIMER: Yeah.
This is like what we
were talking earlier
about the problems
with microservices
and really understanding
what's dependent on what.
This just makes it crystal
clear exactly what's being used.
SCOTT GANYO: So you can see
exactly what's going on.
In addition-- now let me
show you the Jaeger UI.
You can actually see traces.
So if I take and pick
one of my requests,
I can actually see the
breakdown of how long it
took at each service and
which service forwarded on
to the next.
CHRIS LATIMER: Yeah.
I mean, you can
imagine if you're
managing a set of
these microservices
and you get a call from the
help desk that says, hey,
this application is
starting to run really slow.
Rather than have to go in
and try to drill into logs
and look at individual
calls, this just
makes it extremely
evident exactly where
the problem's happening.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
It's all right
here and it's live.
So as soon as I
send a new request,
you would see that
request as well.
In addition, of course, you have
some of the cool Grafana stuff.
There's a number of different
dashboards that come with.
Obviously, you can
set up your own.
I like to see the
workloads and how
they're responding across time.
And you can see, obviously, I
haven't made a lot of requests
here.
But just the requests
that I have made
are showing up
right here for you.
Oh, sorry about that.
CHRIS LATIMER: I mean,
this would be great
if you're somebody
in operations and you
want to be able to look and
see if things are getting out
of the normal, healthy band.
This, again, just makes it--
the nice thing about
this is it really
addresses the
individual personas
and the individual roles that
you have in an organization
and what everybody needs
to see specifically.
SCOTT GANYO: Exactly, exactly.
And then we also
have Prometheus.
That also shows you another
view of this information,
and you can see either a
graph or a console of exactly
how the requests came
through and all the log
details on that.
CHRIS LATIMER: And
again this is all
being generated in real time,
all through that adapter.
You didn't go in
and write code in
each individual microservice.
Everything that
you see here, this
is all coming just from the fact
that you plugged your services
into the Istio framework.
SCOTT GANYO: Just
the fact that you
deployed on Istio, absolutely.
OK.
So I'm going to hand
it back to you, then.
CHRIS LATIMER: Great.
Thanks a lot.
So that's really
service management.
So you can see there's
a lot of advantages that
come with Istio out of the box.
So we talked a
little bit earlier
about some of the challenges
we have with monoliths
in terms of agility.
You saw Scott show
three different versions
of that service that was
live at the same time.
Now, he was refreshing
and we were sending
those sort of arbitrarily.
In a normal type of
real world situation,
what we would want
to do is we want
to look at that service graph.
We would want to understand
where might my next version
cause and breaking changes,
and be more deliberate in terms
of how we roll those
out and how we're
handling those dependencies.
But right away,
you can see there's
a lot of benefits that
come from Istio just right
out of the box.
But now, what if we want
to take one of those
services that we
built out in Istio
and we want to externalize that.
We want to turn that into
a more traditional API.
Maybe we want to expose it
within our organization,
to partners, or we
want to put it out
for anyone on the internet.
Generally, that's
where we start to think
about API management
coming into play
and we start to think of
these as more traditional API
management problems to solve.
And so let's talk a little
bit about API management
and what it is and what
people are typically
looking at when they want to
implement an API management
solution.
Usually, we're
thinking about tools
for humans that are going
to be building applications
using these APIs.
And often that starts with
an API catalog of some sort.
We want to make it
very easy for people
to look into the catalog, browse
through, search through, find
the APIs that are
available, then look
at documentation for those APIs
to understand how it works.
We usually want to have some
type of self-service mechanism
so that if you decide
this API is going
to work in my
particular application,
I can just simply sign up for
an API key or OAuth credentials,
and I can start to build my
application on top of those.
We also want to
think about features
that are applicable for
an API product manager.
So a lot of times with APIs,
we have different types
of consumers that are
going to be using these.
We may have a
public program where
we want to have a silver,
gold, and platinum
tier of our product.
Maybe we want to
monetize those as well.
Or maybe we just
want to productize
those for different types
of internal and external
consumers.
Maybe we have
applications that we've
built which are maybe our
call center app, maybe
our mobile app, and
we know that they're
going to have higher
traffic than some others.
We want to prioritize
that traffic.
We want to give them
higher entitlements to use.
And then, again, from a
product management standpoint,
often we want to look at how
our APIs are actually behaving,
how they're being used.
If we roll out a new feature
in the API, we want to see
are people actually using
this in their applications
and we want to be able to take
advantage of the visibility
that API management gives us.
Now, traditionally,
the way that we
tie in our runtime
aspects of APIs
from the configuration
is with something
called an API gateway.
And usually these are a
centralized enforcement point
where we might put
these in our DMZ,
we might put these--
the appropriate point
in our network to provide
centralized control over things
like access control.
We might want to have OAuth
or API key validation or job
validation.
We might want to put in
place throttling or threat
protection, edge caching, or
more complex transformations
and mediations.
And these work great
for traditional APIs.
The question we get
quite a bit is that what
if I'm in a service
mesh and I already have
a sidecar proxy that's running.
It's already
intercepting my traffic.
I don't necessarily want
to put another component
into my architecture and have
an additional network hop, so
how can we avoid that?
So the good news is we've
built API management for Istio.
And what this
allows you to do is
it allows you to take all of the
runtime capabilities of Istio
and apply policies
from API management.
Now, one of the next questions
we often get is, well,
do I need API management
for all my services?
And in general, no.
You want to pick and choose
where it's appropriate.
So with a lot of
services, you may
have things that are completely
internal to your service mesh.
They may only be called
by other services.
You never want to take
those capabilities,
open those up, and expose
for people to consume.
And other times,
you'll have things
that are very
applicable that you
know you can put
into mobile apps,
and into other applications
and get all kinds of business
value out of those.
And those are the
places where we
want to enforce API
management rules.
So how are these different?
Because a lot of times
we'll look at this
and say, well, it seems
like Istio has a gateway,
Apigee as a gateway.
Istio has some things
for authentication.
So does Apigee.
So what are the different
times and approaches
that we might take in one
situation versus another?
So one of the biggest
things that you'll
see right off the bat is
that with API management,
we're generally thinking
about HTTP-based APIs, things
that are very specifically at
that L7 layer of the network.
With Istio, we have more control
over what we can actually
manage.
So we can do things
that the L3, L4 layers,
as well as the L7 layers.
From an authentication
authorization perspective,
Istio is very much interested
in service identities.
So we talked about Citadel.
We talked about
the ability to use
MTLS and certificate-based
authentication
and authorization approaches.
With API management,
we're generally
thinking about things like OAuth
and we're thinking about jots
and we're thinking
about API keys
that applications
are going to use
so we can identify those
apps when a call comes in.
We'll also see differences
in terms of things
like rate limiting.
So from a service
perspective, we're
usually wanting to
put at a service
level rules about how the
service is going to be,
limits around how the
service can be used,
how often it can be called.
And rate limits from
an API perspective
are often going to be more
around the use case that's
happening.
So again, we'll see a lot of
companies that are opening up
APIs to the public.
And they want to
have different tiers
and different
monetization packages that
go along with those.
Those are really much more
of it API management problem,
that we want to think about
API management solutions
versus service management.
And then from a portal
perspective, again,
from the main consumer
and service management
is going to be other services.
Whereas from an API
management perspective,
we're thinking about people
that are building the apps.
We're really thinking
about the humans that
are out there that
are building apps that
are going to use these APIs.
And for that reason,
we tend to think
of a portal as a more
foundational component of API
management.
So what does this
actually look like when
we think about Apigee
API management and Istio?
So if we started up with just
a pure service management
approach, we've
got the components
we've talked about before.
We've got a side car proxy
that we've deployed along
with our microservice.
We've configured Pilot to send
the necessary configuration
into Mixer and into the proxy.
And we configured Mixer to
be able to enforce those.
Now, if we want to apply
API management rules,
the good news is
Mixer is extensible.
So Mixer gives us
all the mechanisms
that we need to apply
API management rules.
So if you start looking at
some of those capabilities
we discussed, things like API
key or OAuth validation, jot
validation, performing
some type of remediation
or transformation, quotas,
and analytic pipelines.
We can actually avoid having
a separate API gateway
and we can tie
into the mechanisms
that Istio gives us using Mixer.
And so what we've done is
we've built an adapter.
When I say we, I really mean
you have built an adapter that
lets us apply all of those
capabilities using the Apigee
platform.
And so again, as interesting
as this picture is,
I think it is much more
interesting if we turn it back
over to Scott and actually
take a look at how
this works in practice.
SCOTT GANYO: All right.
Yep, yep.
No, actually, I think that
was a fascinating picture.
It's actually a
good one if you want
to go back and understand how
all these pieces fit together.
But we're going to go back to
our little Bookinfo application
here.
And the one thing
that was missing
before is we had
an app and people
could go and look up
this book information.
But now, if I wanted to write
my own app on top of that,
how would I do that?
Or if I'm the Bookinfo
provider, how do I give that
to other developers?
And the way we're going
to do that is we're
just going expose,
for our example here,
the details
information as an API.
So first off, get over
here and show you.
What we're going to do first
is expose a virtual service
to allow the details
information to be provided
to the outside world, outside
of the mesh, the service mesh.
And a virtual service is
really just a set of endpoints
that you want to expose.
And the default service shows--
you can see here that
you have a product page,
log in, log out,
things like that.
All that is part
of the application.
And what we're doing is adding
this little-- oops, sorry--
adding this little bit here
at the bottom which says,
I want to expose
details directly out.
And this will actually go expose
this virtual service here.
And all we have to do is
apply that using the Kube,
the Kube control.
So it's a Kubernetes.
CHRIS LATIMER: So
basically, what you're doing
is you're telling Istio,
I've got a new API.
It's a virtual service.
Here are the paths
that is going to expect
that you should be able to
apply policies on these.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
CHRIS LATIMER: Here's the
prefix that you should look at.
And now you're going to use
kubectl to actually send
that configuration in.
SCOTT GANYO: Yes.
Yes.
So you can see, I've created--
configured the Bookinfo.
And now we should be able to
actually do a curl on that.
And this is live, by the way.
This is not made up.
This is an existing
system I installed,
just like it's the same Bookinfo
system that I showed you
in the beginning.
And now we're actually
getting a JSON payload back
from my details page.
CHRIS LATIMER: And
so now this call
actually went right to
that virtual service
that you just
configured in Istio.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
Right.
And service was already there.
I just changed the routing
so I could get to it.
CHRIS LATIMER: So we showed
that in the previous example.
You had this all set up.
This is the Bookinfo app.
And in fact, if you
want, we'll show
later you can go into Istio.io
and this is a sample app that
comes with the platform.
SCOTT GANYO: Right, right.
So so now we have the API.
the Problem, of course,
is nobody knows about it.
It's unprotected.
Nobody knows how to use it.
None of that's good, right?
That's just an accident
waiting to happen.
So what we want to do is start
managing it through Apigee.
And what I'm going
to do here is--
so this first little bit is
a one-time configuration.
It just tells
Istio about Apigee,
that the adapter exists.
CHRIS LATIMER: So
this is the mechanism
we talked about the fact
that Mixer is extensible.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
CHRIS LATIMER: And so you
built that extension and this
is you telling Istio,
now you want to use
that extension in your mesh.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
So the first part
here just declares
that there is an Apigee
adapter in the configuration.
The next one defines a
template for my analytics
because I want to pull
information out of Istio
and give it to Apigee
so that it also
can report on this information.
There's an instance
configuration
for that that just tells
us which attributes
of out of Istio
we want, and then
a template for
authorization that tells us
which attributes we're looking
for, for example, an API key.
CHRIS LATIMER: So
that right there,
that's the hook in that we
have from sort of the Istio
configuration into what Apigee
is expecting so we can--
SCOTT GANYO: Right, right.
CHRIS LATIMER: --apply
those policies.
SCOTT GANYO: It's part of what
you might call installation
is to set this up.
The next thing we want to do
is we define an Apigee handler.
So now, this tells us--
this tells Istio the
adapter that we just
created, how to connect
to an Apigee environment.
So you have an organization
and environment set up
as part of Apigee that
actually tells your system
how to do the authentication
and authorization, quota,
and things like that.
And this will actually
connect that, create it.
And then, finally, we're
going to define a rule.
And what the rule does is
tells Istio, all right,
under these conditions
apply Apigee management.
And in this case, we're
just-- it's a simple rule.
We're going to say, when the
destination service is details.
So it won't affect the
rest, but when it's details,
we're going to send
authorization the Apigee
and send the
analytics to Apigee.
CHRIS LATIMER: So
you took the handler,
so that's basically
the request handler.
And you're telling
Istio that this is how
we're going to handle requests.
And then you configure
this rule that says, here
are the rules that we
actually want to apply--
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
When
CHRIS LATIMER: --when
see a request matching
these specific conditions.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
So now at this point, Apigee
is in control of that API.
So if we attempt to
access that, we're
going to hit the authentication
authorization, quota
management, and it's
going to report on that.
And let's actually,
first off, let's look
at what Apigee
actually looks like
and how we define
that information here.
As you can see, I've
set up this already.
So this is a product that
I've set up for developers
to be able to access.
And you can see here
that when you set it up,
you can set up
multiple environments
and apply them as you wish.
Now, Mixer only attaches
to one of the environments.
So you can have two versions of
it or whatever you want to do,
but you have that access.
You have key
approval, which we'll
see when you get to the portal.
You have a quota.
I set up a quota of five
requests every minute.
That's pretty low, but we
want to see how that works.
CHRIS LATIMER: It's
easier than showing you
1,000 requests per second.
SCOTT GANYO: Exactly.
Right, exactly
CHRIS LATIMER: Scott trying
to click 1,000 times.
So we talked about
productization.
So this is the
mechanism in Apigee.
We have the productization
and API products.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
And this also is live.
So if I change it, it will be
automatically updated in Istio.
And you also have
resource paths.
And down here you can see--
it's a little bit
small, perhaps.
But you can see that the service
that I want to connect to
is listed there.
So I say that I'm going to the
details.default dot service
cluster local.
That's just a
Kubernetes DNS name.
CHRIS LATIMER: That's
the service and where
you can find the service.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
And it tells us right there.
So let's go back here and
now that we've protected it,
we can't get to it.
So nobody can get to it
without an API key anymore.
Well, so how do we
get the API key?
Well, I mentioned the
developer portal--
sorry.
So let's take a look at that.
Now, I've already
created a portal.
And basically, it just involves
selecting a few things,
selecting which products
you want to make available.
And I've logged in.
So I you to see the app.
So I created an app
and said, OK, I want
to access the details page.
And my app then says,
OK, I have access here
to this product, the Bookinfo
details and I have a key here.
And I have a secret.
So normally, I would take
this key and copy it.
I've already done
that for us here.
And you can see here's
the key that we got.
And I'm going to run the same
command, only this time I'm
going to pass it an API key.
And now I have access again.
CHRIS LATIMER: Ta-da.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
So now we've protected
it, which is great.
And authorization is done there,
too, as far as path access
and things like that.
I allowed any path.
So now developers
can hit our APIs.
That's cool.
So what do we know about them?
Well, now we can
go back into Apigee
and we can look at
developer engagement
and we can see that, actually,
this is my developer here.
It's a little small again.
Sorry.
And we can see other things
like proxy performance.
And we can narrow that down
to just the details page
and see that information.
CHRIS LATIMER: And this isn't
an either/or proposition.
We can still get Istio
analytics on this service.
SCOTT GANYO: Absolutely.
All of that is still happening.
CHRIS LATIMER: We
can also now augment
that with Apigee's analytics.
SCOTT GANYO: Absolutely, 100%.
CHRIS LATIMER: Very cool.
SCOTT GANYO: Yeah.
All right.
So let's get back.
We have the quota.
So here I set up
a little script.
It's going to hit it a
bunch of times really quick.
And--
CHRIS LATIMER: There we go.
SCOTT GANYO: All right.
So for this key, my
developer can only
access it five times a minute.
And each one, each developer
has that same quota.
So what have we done?
We've exposed the API,
published it to the portal,
required a key to access it.
We allowed developers to
register and get those keys.
And we can set per
developer quota limits.
So one more thing--
I think we have time.
I just want to show you
that we can also OAuth.
So here's an OAuth
definition, and I'm not going
to spend too much time on it.
You can specify an issuer and
cert URL and things like that.
I'm going to apply that.
Now, I need to generate a token.
Part of that is I need
to not only have the key,
but now I need to
have the secret.
So here, put the secret in here.
And this is just a little
script that generates a token
and does the call.
And you can see that
I'm just doing the curl
again, this time
with a bare token.
So you see, a
token was generated
and something didn't work.
Let me just try it again.
All right.
It doesn't like something.
CHRIS LATIMER: That's
still pretty good.
SCOTT GANYO: I don't
think we have--
CHRIS LATIMER: That's
still pretty good.
We've got all the
way through the demo.
There's been only one hiccup.
SCOTT GANYO: We don't have
time to debug that right now.
CHRIS LATIMER: I'm going
to count that as a success,
regardless.
SCOTT GANYO: All right.
So let's get back
to wrapping up here.
CHRIS LATIMER: So
hopefully, after this demo,
you can see you've got a
lot of great capabilities
that come with Istio.
It's going to solve a lot
of those core microservices
problems that you're
going to run into as you
try to scale microservices.
And then inevitably,
when you need
to take one of
those micro services
you need to expose
that out as an API
and you need traditional
API management,
we've made it very easy with
API management for Istio
to tie into all the
capabilities of Apigee
and build that right
into the platform.
So you really have a
seamless developer experience
that you can take advantage of.
Now, I'm sure many of you are
probably wondering, what next?
This was great
content, but I'd like
to dive a little bit deeper.
So the good news is we've
got a great write-up for you
on the Apigee API
management for Istio plug-in
that Scott just went through.
And don't worry if
you don't have time
to write down these links.
We're going to put
those into the Q&A
and you can grab
them from there.
If you're building
microservices,
we also have an
e-book that we've
taken all the lessons
learned from our customers
and we've built out a
great resource for you
to learn about what's
worked and what's
not worked at our
customers as they're
building out microservices.
And then if you want to get
hands-on with the platform,
if you're not an
existing Apigee customer,
we have a free version for you.
You can sign up today
for an evaluation.
You can start playing
around with it.
You can run through the same
example that Scott just did.
And if you are an
existing Apigee customer,
the documentation is live.
You can go out there today.
You can learn more
about API management
for Istio using the
Apigee platform.
And with that, we're going
to take a quick break.
So in roughly a minute,
we're going to come back
and we're going to have the
live Q&A, so stick around
and we'll be right back.
So great.
Looks like we have
some questions,
so let's go ahead and
address those now.
I'll start with the first one.
So Scott, I'll direct
this one at you.
So does Istio work for
workloads running on VMs?
If yes, can you
please explain how?
SCOTT GANYO: Yeah.
Well, absolutely, it does.
It's designed to be independent
of Kubernetes, mostly.
What you would end up doing
is, through the mesh expansion
abilities, you can
actually run the proxy
next to any container, anywhere.
It just has to have access
back to the main Istio--
the Pilot has to be
able to configure it.
And it has to be able
to access the Mixer
and the other components
of the system.
CHRIS LATIMER: So
yeah, absolutely.
If you're running most
of your workloads on VMs,
you're not on Kubernetes
yet, Istio is still
extremely valuable for you.
So let's jump to the second one.
What is the difference
between analytics
provided by Apigee and
the one provided by Istio?
So again, I think we
actually saw quite a bit
of this in the demo.
So some of the things that we
saw on there were Istio has--
so the way Istio
analytics work are really
with that telemetry adapter.
And you can take that data
that's coming into Istio
and you can put it
wherever you'd like.
So we've used that same
mechanism in Apigee
to take the data
that's coming in
and feed into Apigee
analytic system.
But we also saw Jaeger,
we saw Prometheus.
And depending on your
role in the organization,
Istio gives you a way to
get access and visibility
into the information you need.
So if you're an
API product manager
and you want to look
at the analytics that
are coming into Apigee,
you've got all the dashboards
that are in Apigee.
If you are a mesh
administrator and you're
looking for ways to track
the dependencies across all
of your mesh, we've got that
in there as well with Istio.
And then, of course, we saw
from the Grafana dashboards
that you looked at a way
for operations people
to get a very quick way to
determine what traffic's
coming in, if
things are suddenly
getting out of the normal
range that we expect to see.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
And I think one
of the key details
is Apigee provides
a higher level view.
It's more tied to your
developers and the analytics
around them, how the product
is being used and utilized.
CHRIS LATIMER: So let's
jump to the next one.
I'll let you handle
this one as well, Scott.
So what kind of data related
to Apigee is cached at envoy?
And maybe we could expand
this to be not just envoy,
but maybe anywhere in Istio.
SCOTT GANYO: Yeah, exactly.
So we don't really
cache data at envoy.
No.
When you-- the only exception
is if you install the OAuth bit.
The envoy actually does
get the public certificate
for validating your jot
tokens, but that's not
even Apigee-specific.
That's just how it
works, how Istio works.
We do cache some data in Mixer.
We cache information
about the API keys,
the jot tokens for the lifetime,
and some product information.
And this is so that we can
respond immediately and not
get in the way of requests
traveling through Istio.
We don't want to go up
to the Apigee server
for every request, as
you can understand.
That would add a lot
of wanted latency.
CHRIS LATIMER: Definitely.
So let's talk about
the next one here.
What are the best ways to secure
communication between Apigee
and the Istio ingress?
And I'm going to say this
is pretty similar to just
like anything else
within Apigee where
we need to secure the
communication between Apigee
and the back end.
We're going to use
standard techniques.
We can use things
like IP whitelisting.
We can use mutual
TLS, one-way TLS.
All the things that you've
come to know and love
in terms of network security
that have been around
for a long time are
still applicable
here right in today's world.
SCOTT GANYO: Right.
And out of the box.
It's, of course, on using
HTTPS for communication.
It actually does communicate
with authentication-- its own
authentication.
I showed you in the
handler the authentication
that you give to
Istio, to the adapter
so that it can authenticate with
the Apigee on there as well.
CHRIS LATIMER: So the last
one that we have here,
so you said the feature is GA.
Can you help us understand how
to start using this feature?
Is it priced separately?
Yes.
So as we showed in the
resources for this, briefly,
and again, that link
should be in the Q&A.
We've got a lot of--
we've got documentation.
We've got a great
write-up in terms
of how to get started
using this feature.
If you want to get
started with just Istio,
Istio.io is the website
that you want to go to.
That's where you can
get started with sort
of just the pure Istio framework
and start working with that.
And then, again, from the
Apigee API management for Istio,
we've got the documentation
that's in the Q and A
so you can read through,
understand how it works.
And then we've got everything
that you need to get started.
Now, if you are an Apigee
customer, a current Apigee
Enterprise customer, and
you're interested in sort
of in the pricing, this
isn't priced separately.
What we're doing is we're--
if you're using our Apigee
Edge micro gateway today,
it's very similar.
We're essentially charging
based on the number of API calls
that are coming through.
So typically, you
have an entitlement
of several hundred
million calls per quarter
or several hundred
million calls per--
billion calls per year--
sorry, tens of billions
of calls per year.
And so what we're doing
is we're essentially
calculating those API
calls that are coming
in through the adapter
for Istio at a 3 to 1
ratio, similar to what we
do for the micro gateway.
And it looks like that
is our last question.
So thank you all so much
for attending this today.
We've enjoyed speaking with
you, enjoyed your questions,
and please stay tuned
for the next session.
We have "Managing Chrome Browser
Updates in the Enterprise."
Thank you.
SCOTT GANYO: Thank you.